our number one priority is economic
stability
and restoring confidence that the United
Kingdom is a country that pays its way
and for that reason the medium-term
fiscal plan is extremely important and I
want to confirm that it will demonstrate
debt falling over the medium term which
is very important for people to
understand
but it's also extremely important that
that statement is based on the most
accurate possible economic forecasts and
forecasts of public finances and for
that reason the Prime Minister and I
have decided that it is prudent to make
that statement on the 17th of November
when it will be upgraded to a full
Autumn statement
and I've discussed this last night with
the governor of the bank of England he
understands the reasons for doing that
and I'll continue to work very closely
with him
it's only 10 days since the governor of
the bank of England said that having the
government's plans first and then the
interest rate decision on the 3rd of
November was the correct order of events
by moving this until after the interest
rate decision aren't you just risking
more uncertainty more chaos more Market
turbulence well there has been a lot of
Market turbulence even in the last 48
hours and the question is how you deal
with that turbulence to make sure that
the very very important and very
difficult decisions that I and the Prime
Minister have to make are the right ones
decisions that stand the test of time
and do the right thing for people at
home who are worried about their
mortgages their jobs the cost of living
the bills and so on and for that reason
accuracy in the forecasts both around
public finances and economic growth is
very important and that's why this is
the right decision and a prudent
decision
you were already getting forecasts from
the obr people look at this delay and
think hang on this is because either the
Prime Minister wants to check your
homework or because the new secretary's
estate are kicking back against the
spending cuts you want for them what
what is the problem here and is it is it
to do with the new cabinet not wanting
to go along with your plans well the obr
also want to make sure that their
forecasts are the most accurate possible
and there have been a lot of changes you
know even in the last 48 hours and this
is my recommendation to the Prime
Minister as the best way to ensure that
the decisions that we take these very
very difficult decisions are ones that
stand the test of time and give us the
best chance of giving people security
over their mortgages over their jobs
over the cost of living concerns that
everyone has this statement has moved
backwards and forwards like someone
learning how to park a car do you feel
any twinge of embarrassment that your
party has led to this having to shift
about like this well I think I have
demonstrated in the short time that I've
been Chancellor that I'm willing to take
decisions very quickly and I'm willing
to make choices that are politically
embarrassing if they're the right thing
to do for the country if they're in the
National interest
now we have a new prime minister and the
prospect of much longer term stability
for the economy in the country and in
that context a short two and a half week
delay is the best way we will make sure
that it is the right decisions we take
and very briefly it's reported today
that one of the reasons the Home
Secretary was sacked last week because
it was because she shared obr sensitive
information are you happy that Sue Ella
Braverman is back as Home Secretary and
would you trust her with sensitive
information well she apologized for her
mistakes she has been fully accountable
for those mistakes she stepped down as
Home Secretary but from the point of
view of people at home who want
stability in the economy they also need
to see a United conservative party and
that's why the Prime Minister has put
together a cabinet of all the talents